Alex hormozzi said it the best so I'm
just gonna leave this to him the single
most important decision that you make of
all decisions in life is who you spend
your life with like as your significant
other you see guys in this podcast we've
discussed everything from money life and
business how could we avoid discussing
relationships yeah I think we've talked
about uh some really interesting
Dynamics and perspectives that I've just
never considered before I think Alex
ramosi is one of them Tom bilyeu is
another that really got me thinking on
so many different aspects I think it's
an incredibly important topic that not a
lot of people really want to dive into I
think it's just it's a bit personal for
people it maybe kind of hits too close
to home and people might be very
opinionated about it but uh I think
there's a lot to learn on this because
who you choose as a spouse is so
incredibly important and there's a lot
we can take away from these podcasts I
mean the Tom Billy you one alone he
talks about how he built up and sold a
business for one billion dollars with
his wife my wife is my equal in every
conceivable way on balance but there are
things that I am way better than her at
and in those moments I lead
and there are things that she's way
better than me at and in those moments I
follow she was instrumental and I think
a lot of that and the support that she
gave him in those early days of like
turning the living room into a shipping
facility and like her packaging orders
like during the day and then running the
entire business from this together I
thought was really cool you'd think that
that would be ripe for disaster right
like working with your fiance or spouse
in a business especially when it's that
big of one you would think but they
started I thought very early on didn't
they it's just like running that
business together uh and I think it made
I think it made sense in that situation
and the hormozy episode as well we have
Layla and Alex both sitting with us
talking about how they built up and sold
gym launch for what was it some like 60
million dollars and it was odd too
because they started out almost as like
business partners like they went on that
one date but then it quickly evolved
from like going on a date to talking
business and then it changed from
business then back to being like a
relationship so today you're gonna hear
their own perspectives on relationships
wealth and making a lot of money and
that's a topic that not a lot of people
talk about and this episode should give
you guys everything you need to have a
successful relationship and business
how's your relationship Jack uh it's not
so great but if I had seen this podcast
uh maybe two months ago I would
definitely have a girlfriend right now
really yes what would have changed uh
you know I I don't think I would have
got that haircut sooner really yeah I've
been telling you to get the haircuts
before we start after you subscribe
we're gonna put uh some relationship
talk at the end Jack has that really
really okay a little bit do you remember
swiping on Alex's profile let's set that
apart well
it was a picture of a guy with a six
pack oh my God no that was the that's
like really that was the water yeah in
the water with sunglasses on it was it
was it was not like in the mirror I was
like at the beach okay literally in the
water so someone else took the baby I
was like I was I've had some floaty or
what whatever that I was like moving and
so I'm just had to like can you tell us
was that it was an old picture okay
which I realized when we met yeah so
that was who it was but it specifically
it was like Fitness and business so it
was like own five gyms
Fitness and then like something else you
you remember expensive steaks cheap
bourbon some expenses takes can you
buying that yeah but I was like oh
business and fitness like that sounds
like me too so that was why I swiped
yeah and then he messaged me immediately
after I messaged him and was like we
should get off the app let's talk on the
phone and that was actually what I
appreciated the most is I was like I'm
so sick of these guys that have like so
much time to waste you know like talking
on these apps not actually like moving
forward to a date I was like this is
just like lame so I actually really
appreciate that he wanted to talk on the
phone biggest reason I believe that our
among the biggest reasons is that Layla
never tried to change me and that was
something that I felt like was a
constant and the majority of the other
relationships that I had was like you're
here I'm here let's meet in the middle
and that's why I have such strong
stances on compromise because I like I
don't think you can compromise on you
you know what I mean and so I always
felt like I had to be less than or a
different version of myself in order to
like make the relationship work and um I
also was in a season where like I just
gotten out of a long relationship like
I'm not really bending the knee to
anyone for anything like I'm not
compromising if you don't like my
schedule then cool like I'm not gonna
stop living how I live and so she just
kind of like
oriented herself around me and it worked
just amazingly well and I got to do what
I want to do all day which is work and
it was great how did you feel about that
did you feel like you needed to
compromise or or bend a little bit to
fit Alex or what was your side of things
on that no honestly I think we got
really lucky because I was kind of
always the same way which is like I'm
not gonna like be less of myself and
like less ambitious and less career
oriented for a man because that was what
typically they wanted of me so I
actually really like the fact that he
wanted to work all the time because I
was just finally somebody that didn't
tell me like oh you need to go do your
hair and look pretty like it was someone
who's like yeah you should learn how to
do this like let's build a [__]
business like let's do all this stuff
like I just love that
he believed in me so much and I think
most men that I had dated at that point
sure I'm sure they believed in me but I
don't think that they wanted me to ever
be any better than I was because they
were worried that it would be better
than them I remember I think it was
either the first or second time we had
U1 you said that there are two different
you know relationship structures that
work well and one is like we're in the
trenches together we're grinding it out
the other one is the cheerleader and the
football player right and what is your
sentiment towards this you said that
we're in the trenches together is more
powerful it's harder to break and it's
just a better overall relationship is
kind of what you were hinting at divorce
rates for people who have made a dollar
together in a business they started
um is 10 so it's significantly lower and
I think maybe that's because there's
like in order to even get to that first
dollar together with somebody like
there's a lot of other things that have
to be aligned and then you also have
this post commitment kind of bias where
you both want to keep this thing alive
and you're both working together towards
like a shared Mission or goal so I think
there's just a lot of alignment that
happens there and there's also a lot of
um context and so one of the things that
I think happens in many relationships is
that people get exposed to different
stimuli and then they adapt to the
stimuli and then they grow apart just
because of the nature of just stimulus
response right and so if you're both in
the same business together you're being
exposed to the same stressors and then
you you can grow together in the same
direction and I think at least for us
that's been our experience rather than
having to like we just have a shared
Mission and so we're on it together I
think it's um something we were talking
about the other day is you know we were
talking to a guy and he was talking
about wanting an open relationship and I
come from the air of like I'm not the
kind of woman who's like oh my husband
should never look at a lot he never
looks at another woman out I assume that
Alex looks at other women because he's a
man like that is what men do and that's
like how we're wired like we're humans
right that's a human thing and I think
what I subscribe to is that if you want
a relationship to last then you have to
create more reasons to stay with the
person than to not because there's
always reasons not to be with somebody
Freedom autonomy you want to go bang
other people whatever it is right it's
like we have all these human instinctual
things that are pulling us in One
Direction
can you create more reasons within your
relationship to stay with that person so
if you work together if you're on the
same Mission together if you have the
same values if you both like Fitness and
Nutri and like all these things those
are all the arguments as to why you want
to be with that person and I think what
happens a lot of relationships they just
don't have much of an argument it's like
cool we like each other and that's it
like I can go [__] 10 other people and
then there's nothing else in common
they're not on the same Mission they
have nothing else to argue so when
things are hard your mind is going to go
why am I with this person it's like I
have a million reasons why I'm with Alex
if we ever have a hard day it's like it
that the thought of exiting doesn't even
cross my mind because there's so much
overwhelming evidence as to why it makes
sense to stay don't you think it
complicates things to also be in
business that maybe not financially you
you have an incentive to stay together I
think I mean absolutely complicates
things in terms of like there are more
there are more layers to the
relationship but I also think that to
the same degree they can compound and
become
even you become even you have more
potential for disruption but also more
more potential for alignment so I'll say
about this which is like me and Alex
when we were dating we broke up for six
weeks
um and we we talked about in the very
beginning of our relationship like if
we're gonna get into business together
and do this together then we need to
know what it would look like if we
weren't together and so when we broke up
we both uphold our end of the bargain
like we were great Partners to each
other without being in a relationship
and so like I look at it like this which
is like if you have to worry about the
exit then you shouldn't be with the
person I don't worry about that with
Alex and I I even we talked about this
the other day I was like it would we
would just do that again you know what I
mean like it would be amicable and so I
think if you have to worry about what it
would look like or we're gonna fight
over money and do stuff it's like then
don't be with the person it's
interesting because I think that like
the single great the single most
important decision that you make of all
decisions in life is who you spend your
life with like as your significant other
and if you look at all the stats in
terms of amount of time spent with
people like times with family basically
drops off at 25 like it's very very low
after that time spent with siblings same
thing time spent with spend with friends
starts dropping off at like 30 pretty
aggressively and then the two that
increase a lot for the majority of your
life are time spent with spouse is
number one and then in between those is
time spent with co-workers so your
co-workers matter way more than your
friends do in terms of hours per day so
like where you work is actually
incredibly important for your overwhelm
like your subjective well-being but like
there's one person that you're gonna
spend the rest of your life with if you
believe in marriage and like the
strength of the relationship you have
with your significant other has a 0.71
correlation to your overall subjective
well-being so more than anything how
well you get along with the person you
spend all your time with which makes
sense you spend the majority of your
time with this person and so I think
that if there's ever something to be
obsessive over it would be that you saw
that chart on Twitter huh which the
chart the X and Y and then you have it
was a bunch of line yeah who posted I
believe that there are mainly three
pillars to a successful relationship
such as shared values shared interests
and just raw chemistry right right I
think those are the three things as long
as you can check those three boxes
everything else obviously it matters to
some extent but those are the main three
boxes you need to check to make sure
your partner is a viable one I swapped
with one of I swap one of them out which
one so chemistry out swap because that's
going to disappear in terms of like
literally your chemical soup and your
brain goes back to normal after two
years so like that that feeling goes
away and so what I would swap with that
is something long term which is Mission
which is do you want to do the same
thing on earth
just like shared Mission values is how
you get so do you want to go to the same
place value this is how you get there
and the interest is the stuff you do
along the way Tony Robbins talks about
it a lot but you can create chemistry
yeah in fact we've talked about it a ton
because we have to manage our chemistry
because of how much we work together
yeah how do you do that space how do you
create space so many ways I mean
independent vacations
[Laughter]
I'm going to Mexico we'll meet back in
the U.S no I mean I think some of it's
physical space which is like you know we
technically work together all day right
but we don't we stay in separate areas
of the house we work on different things
like we're very segmented in terms of
our responsibilities set in terms of
what we do in the business and outside
and then on the other side of that it's
being able to switch hats which is
there's Alex and Layla that work
together and you see in the public eye
and then there's Alex and Layla that are
themselves in their condo when nobody's
their husband and wife and so it's being
able to switch between those two
Dynamics because if you constantly keep
on the work hat then like there's no
chemistry you know what I mean because
what happens is you're not it's the side
of you that provokes chemistry and the
person like for a woman right for me
it's like am I being feminine I'm
playful and funny and you know
light-hearted well it's like at work I'm
not going to beat those things because
it's more of like a masculine energy at
work where you're like driving things
forward making decisions like very
decisive outspoken so for me it's been
learning how to swap the hats and I
think we've both worked on that a lot
over the years
um so now it feels easy I mean now it
feels like the moment people leave like
we talk in a different voice yeah like
our manners
I do a little bit Yeah like a little
playful
um no I think I think the things that's
improved is that we've got our our speed
to be able to change gears has improved
so what used to maybe take like an hour
or two hours to wind down like to switch
gears is now like we can do it in almost
an instant
um and so that's that's been like being
able to shift energy is really like the
the Crux of it like you can feel like
right now you have business Alex and
Layla like this is like we can talk
objectively about the marriage but this
isn't like our relationship Dynamic you
know what I mean this is our work
dynamic because this is work you know I
mean for us you know what I mean but
when we are when we're you know at home
alone like
we're pretty playful you know what I
mean like we we tell a lot of jokes we
like we'll we'll [__] with each other a
lot like there's a lot of practical
flights and stuff just like we're really
funny yeah there's a lot of games like
we just yeah we're pretty goofy and
we're it's incredibly light-hearted
which is a strong juxtapose against
probably what most people see which is
just like hard charging incredibly
stoic Work Hard Play Hard business yeah
but what if something's going on with
the business between you two maybe a
disagreement that you have on that how
does that not bleed over and affect that
part we've had disagreements and we've
walked out the door and looked at each
other and just said I love you yeah and
then we just move on to like we're not
in this disagreement currently and and
being in a dis and like again this like
I think we're very fortunate with this
because
so as a reminder to the audience like we
pretty much started doing business
together day one and so like we've only
had a business Dynamic if anything we
had to work harder on the relationships
are the Romantic side then the business
side so like business came natural to us
like it was like a first language for us
and then we learned the romance act
which is why she was saying like you can
create chemistry like you can do it like
you just do the things and like the
camera she's there with disagreements we
they're short-lived and a lot of times
like I think we're pretty good at
compartmentalizing it like if we
disagree about something we know that we
are aligned with the same Mission we
know we're aligned with the same values
and so the only thing that we will
disagree about is like the best way to
get there and a lot of times I think
both of us are like
is this a hill you're going to die on
and neither of us really die on many
Hills and so it's only if we do it's
really important it's shared probably
yeah and one of the rules that we had
which is one of the most important roles
we had in the very beginning of our
relationship was we had this like
Guru or whatever like talked to us and
he was like
I don't know what that was yeah I don't
know what it was but like the advice was
good and he said if you don't agree on
something don't move forward and for
whatever reason it struck Us in the
moment and we have stuck to that which
is like and usually it's like Alex wants
to do something and Layla's like I'm not
sure and because of the positive
reinforcement that I've had earlier on
in our relationship from like most times
where I was like I'm gonna do this thing
she was like I don't think that's a good
idea and I did it anyways most times
those things blew up and so she has a
very good track record for that and so
now we have like a very like we like to
joke that like if I weren't here we
wouldn't have a business but if Layla
were not here I would have a hundred and
also not have a business and so it's
like it's the it's the drawbridge it's
the tension between these two extremes
which is where I think the magic happens
for us I get this question something
we're like well somebody's got to have
veto right right so if you're if you're
at a standstill we just don't like I
don't think that's real like if you're
in a business and you disagree you keep
talking about it until you agree like it
just you keep beating the idea and
thinking about upsides and downsides and
risk Etc exposure and then you're like
I see where you're coming from let's
emphasize that you know like you just
keep solving for it and I think being
open and not taking it personally
especially we're in the business setting
because we both know because we've done
this enough times that like we both just
want to win
and so it's just like how we both have a
hundred percent alignment so just like
we don't take it personal how do you
keep the emotions out of it I think that
we are able to admit when we are
emotional yeah exactly so if I'm if
we're in a some kind of disagreement
I'll be like listen I'm just too
stressed with this like I need to go on
a walk or something and then let's talk
about it later or if Alex you might be
like I'm too angry like let's I'm gonna
go do something and we'll talk about it
later so I think we usually are pretty
self-aware of like if we're in an
emotional state and if we are we try to
wait until we're not to then come back
and talk about it then you know what I
mean I think it's a really big point is
that like we don't we actively avoid
discussion when there's emotional charge
it's just not productive you know what I
mean yeah and even sometimes like I mean
I as a woman it's like I have to catch
myself and be like Oh I'm acting crazy
right now I'm gonna go and he's like and
I'm like yeah I'm gonna go because I'm
acting like crazy [__] and like I can
now catch myself within like two minutes
like we'll be in a conversation and it's
like if I can feel that I'm just being
emotional like oh so sorry crazy going
leaving now exiting myself from the room
how do you take a step back do you just
go on a different room do you
go do a workout how do you do that
really interesting so one of the things
that we found this has just worked well
for us is that be it text like text
communication we are really good
and so like it kind of removes it gives
you it gives you a little bit more time
to say what you're going to say you know
what I mean there's also a record of it
you know what I mean and so if we're
honestly it's like it's been something
that we've done a lot which is like if
we're in a disagreement we'll like type
it out and typing it out it gives it
literally gives you delay between when
you feel something and when something
gets delivered and you get to see it
before like you don't have the slips of
the tongue because you see the words and
you're like committing to them when you
send them and that's been honestly one
of the at least from a tactical
perspective one of the most valuable
things that we've done to like defuse
situations I think it works if you're
logical which we are we both want to
discuss things in a reasonable logical
manner I think if you're really just
emotional you're just gonna find a
reason as to why texting doesn't work
because you can't because emotion
doesn't have a good argument right so
when you type it out it doesn't make any
sense we've also learned how to how to
disagree with each other more
productively and how to manage each
other when we're in emotional state so
like if Alex is angry like back is six
years ago I probably made him more angry
when I was trying to help him not be
angry now I feel like I understand what
diffuses Alex she's really good at
diffusing what diffuses it
it's being really nice honestly a lot of
the times it's like I turn into like a
cute little ball of fun she basically
turns on her like her relationship hat
and then like it I I it's like you can't
hit a puppy you know what I mean like
you can but like but like it's a lot
harder yeah and so if I'm like in this
very like aggressive you know what I
mean like Zone and she's just being like
really cute and kind of vulnerable I
like it it I defuse really quickly he
can't help but laugh you know what I
mean or smile I just have this right
smile and be like all right you know I
mean heard you know what I mean and then
it like we kind of go from there and
like for Layla a lot of times like she
just like she just needs like a long hug
and being like it's okay you know what I
mean like it's totally get stressed he
gets angry like she gets stressed I get
angry and so for me it's like it's okay
like you can feel this way and it's
totally fine and normal yeah when was
the decision to get married 11 months
after dating after our first date yeah
11 months in yeah it was uh six days
later
we had talked about it like a couple
times up until then I think it's more
just like we were like we like looked up
one day and I think people in the
business were asking us they were like
are you guys gonna get buried and I was
like I don't know I'm So Young you know
she's 23. and then we started talking
about we're like interesting they're all
asking us if we're getting married and
we're like do they feel like it's not
stable well that was actually a big
point they were like job security wise
like we feel weird you know committing
to this and you guys aren't even
committed to each other you know what I
mean like what happens if you guys break
up and both of us were like we just keep
doing the same thing like we'll keep
running this business nobody believes
you though yeah No One Believes you but
like as a side note for the dudes who
are like considering getting a girl into
their into their business like you have
to have objectively been willing to pick
that girl of all people to do that role
what I think happens more often is guys
are like man I want to involve my wife
in the business who doesn't really like
business and then they pull them in they
don't give them the respect because
maybe that's not warranted because they
don't have the Acumen for it or whatever
and then they give them kind of a peon
roll which that doesn't necessarily
breed even more respect
um so that they can be like quote
involved
I think like
the role has to be the role that you
would pick for that person even if you
had no dog in the fight like if you
didn't have the relationship like if we
weren't together I would still want
Layla basically running all the
companies because she's great at it
that's why we do well
yeah it's 100 Merit and so like we just
get the benefit of the fact that like
we're also married but like skills first
like the position has to be earned so do
you think the marriage was in a way to
satisfy business partners yeah and so it
was the it was the employees yeah and
then so I so I came back or go ahead
yeah I mean I I yeah I think it was a
mix of things I mean I think I wouldn't
say the employees are the reason that we
got married I think yeah I think it was
just like it just felt like it made a
lot of sense I mean honestly that's like
what we came to it's just like this
makes a ton of sense like we're running
a business together we're romantically
involved we're building the same
together it looks like it's like blowing
up we're like it just makes more sense
to get married than it doesn't did you
have a contract prior to then in terms
of what would happen if you guys split
like who owns what and who gets what or
no well I mean we didn't have much but
but Alex did this was growing at that
point it was growing but I think at that
point did we both have 50 50 things
at that point yeah the business was
yours at that point yeah I just didn't
even you know it's so weird because like
I never even thought about that because
like literally what I did test is women
who take things from men like when I I
won't tell that but
seeing that women are willing to take
something from a man rather than start
over and like get your like it was just
never even in my mind like a possibility
you know what I mean like I was like I
would rather jump off a cliff than take
money from somebody so I actually asked
Leila to sign a prenup because I think
I'd like 250 Grand or something
squirreled away
um and she was like sure whatever and
the fact that she was just like so
effortlessly a yes and I had actually
asked a former relationship to sign a
prenup and it was like a big deal and
very painful and horrible and whatever
the fact that she was just like sure no
problem when we were on the way to like
get it notarized or whatever I actually
just tore it up and threw it out the
window I was like we're good you know I
mean like you've risked everything at
every single point you like you chose me
and wanted to do this thing together
like let's do it you know what I mean
and so I um yeah when my proposal I
didn't have a ring I was just like I
think the actual question was I think it
would make sense if we got married what
do you think
how much forethought did you give the
wedding or or the proposal in general
was was like from start to finish was it
like a week a month
with flowers
I mean it's funny because like I I say
what I said earlier like it is the most
important decision but like the so this
is counter-cultural is that if you look
at like the ROM comps right that are out
there there's usually like Mr right and
then like the old flame from home right
and then they have to like break up with
Mr Right to be with the old flame but
the reason they don't have like sequels
for rom-coms is because then you'd have
two people who are married and have no
reason to be together and so it would be
a very boring movie that would just be
like a miserable marriage and so I
actually think that Mr Wright the one
that makes sense on paper that you have
all the logical reasons to be together
is the person that Hollywood should be
getting people to get married to because
when the chemistry Fades you need to
have rational reasons to be with that
person because like when bad days come
and they will you need to still be like
this makes sense right it still makes
sense when it doesn't make sense and you
don't have the feeling it's tough right
and so
um I remember I was listing it out
because when we were like in this one
marriage discussion I was like I mean
you have the cultural background which
is just a bonus like I never looked for
like a Persian girl but like the fact
that she was was great
um so she understand kind of the
cultural background of my whole family
and whatnot she loved business which was
awesome and she loved Fitness and like
being active and eating healthy and
working out and like that was pretty
much the only three things that like
were interesting or you know and she was
kind right and like trustworthy and she
had character and so I was like I don't
I didn't see a world where there was a
high likelihood that I would find
somebody else that had all those things
and had already sacrificed all these
things to be you know to do this thing
and it's shown efficacy at being good at
it
I was like I just feel like it makes
sense if we get married and she was she
was like yeah and so she said yes and
then we literally I was like I just need
to get you a ring so we'd got in the car
drove the jewelry store bought a ring we
both liked the same ones so she got that
drove back called the pastor and I was
like when are you free and he was like
this Wednesday he's like are you sure
this is fast and we're like yeah we're
good and so the whole week leading up
was six days from then until we got
married and she was like who's gonna
chicken out and um it was crazy is that
I had backed out of a wedding which is
really hard by the way
um super hard yeah expectations on both
sides like invites all this stuff
um but I thought I was gonna like I
thought that I had commitment issues
but it was just that in my gut I knew it
was the right person and I think that
was the like that's why I commanded you
so it's like it's just a lot of people
haven't found the right person like if
you like if you're like not if you don't
know you know kind of thing and so it
just made sense to do it and so then we
got married in the back of a church on a
Wednesday night
um with no family nothing there was like
some local friends who showed up like
five six people and that was it and to
someone that's been dating someone else
for let's say a year two maybe three
years how do they know to make that
final like you know to tie the ribbon to
make sure okay you are going to be my
spouse how do what is the deciding
factoring that to someone who's been
dating someone for a while I mean I
think I don't think that there is a
deciding factor in the in this context
of I don't think everyone has to get
married you know what I mean like I
think we want to to get married and like
we both see ourselves like being with
somebody like we would like to have this
marriage for the rest of our lives like
that's something that we've communicated
to each other but I think a lot of
people don't want that and so I think a
lot of people should take one step back
and think like do do I even want
marriage and if so what's the purpose
because I think that it's going to
become less and less popular in my
opinion
um and there's a lot of people it
doesn't really make sense for like it
really doesn't have a lot of benefits
um particularly like you look at like
the decline on birth rates and stuff
like if you're not gonna have kids like
if you don't have kids you don't share a
business together you don't share a lot
of your lives together like I don't
really understand why someone would get
married in the very beginning of our
marriage we did a lot of uh we went
through like courses and workshops on uh
divorced and at-risk marriages so we
started going through all these
workshops of people who are like trying
to figure out their marriage and we
learned a ton of stuff about like how to
communicate and like expectation setting
and just a lot of really interesting
things and um I think it served us well
so I highly recommend going through like
divorce and like Crisis marriage
counseling type stuff what did you learn
from that I think
one fundamental thing that has to be
learned in order to have a productive
relationship with so many of the
opposite sex is like how men and women
are different like how our brains work
differently how we think differently how
we receive love and affection
differently or respect
um and I think that that teaches you how
you can't treat your partner like you
want to be treated yeah you have to
learn to treat your partner like they
want to be treated and I think that
that's fundamentally hard to learn when
you're not of the same sex so it's like
you have to learn like how does a guy
want to be treated how does a guy
receive love how does a woman want to be
treated how does a woman receive love
and I think that was a huge piece of it
along with understanding like the kind
of protection mechanisms that we had
each built up along the way that had
created walls between us and I think
that those walls took a couple of years
to probably come down maybe two or three
because like I know for myself like over
the years like you build up walls that
keep you from getting hurt but they also
keep you from getting super close to
somebody and I think everybody has those
it's completely normal and you shouldn't
wait to find someone to you know until
those walls are down I think it's you
learn how to take them down with your
partner yeah and so it's like you become
aware of them yourself and then you
explain floor that with your partner you
talk about it openly and then you talk
about how you're going to work on it and
I think that being able to communicate
those few things with each other was
huge for us like I used to be very cold
and I wouldn't tell Alex anything that
was on my mind I mean I was extremely
closed off and that was really tough for
me and for him and for me one of the
things that I had to work on the most
was
learning how to just communicate what I
was actually thinking and not be so
terrified that he would judge me or you
know leave or mad at me or anything
because just for some reason I just
never I always was like used to doing
things on my own and so feeling like I
could even tell somebody else how I was
feeling about anything was like
so incredibly overwhelming for me and
now it's normal and I can you know if
anything it's like maybe five minutes of
me not telling him but it used to be
weeks yeah what do you think you had to
work on
it's great you know I'm not that yet I
think I think uh my temper has gotten a
lot better
um that's that's a big one uh my timer's
got a lot better
um because I think what it was is like
your if Alex would get angry then Layla
would recoil yeah it was like and then
it was not a productive relationship so
you worked a ton on understanding like
anger
didn't work with me at all very true
like I would just get more aggressive
and then she like she would just shut
down and so I just had to like I just
had to create more space and learn how
to like okay
like this is what we want to do these
are the values that like that's why it's
like the mission values interested so at
least for us is so important it's like
if we're aligned on these things and it
means that all we have for the nine
times out of ten it's a miscommunication
like nine times out of ten it just means
like I took something that you said the
way that you probably didn't intend it
so let's just break down what you said
and how I took it and then she's like I
didn't mean that to disrespect you I was
like well here's when you say this I was
like this is what I hear she's like I
did not mean that and so like I think
over time like you just know that there
are trigger sentences or whatever that
I'm like I could probably work on this
but it'd be a hell of a lot easier if
you just don't say that and I will also
concurrently try to work on it if it
slips out I think we have so much
ability to influence our partners and we
have to be careful with that you know
what I mean because it's like I only
want to encourage Alex and I'm sure Alex
only wants to encourage me but we can
say things and not know that we're
discouraging the other person to spy our
behaviors and our actions and is it our
full responsibility no but it was it's
definitely helpful if you know how to
positively affect that person rather
than negatively and I think a lot of
people in relationships actually
negatively impact their Partners more
than they positively do and that's why
people break up because if they look at
that area of their life and many other
areas they're negatively impacted once
they get with that person you know it's
like they look at the time they got in
the relationship it's like health wealth
all these friends everything it's like
it all goes down versus you know for us
it all went up I had a I had a mentor so
you asked the question way earlier about
like how do you know if it's like the
right person I don't think there's like
a one fits all but I asked this to a
coach that I had at the time who was
kind of like basically helping me deal
with the anxiety that I was going
through and all that stuff was happening
and he was like just look at your stats
that's what he told me he's like just
look at your stats he's like
how are you Fitness wise I was like is
it up or down being with her I was like
well she goes to the gym all the time
she like does all the meal prep like
it's up I'm definitely like better
because she's there he's like all right
what about the business stuff I was like
well
I was like well she makes me money and
he was like has any other girl made you
money I was like no and he's like well
that's a plus right and I was like okay
and so you know we just went down the
line of like what are the things that no
matter most to me and like are they
pluses or minuses and all of them were
up my stats were up since I've been with
Leyland I never like really thought
through that and I was like oh like this
logically like I'm better for being with
her and so it was also like how's your
headspace are you more you know what I
mean you know like you feel like you're
becoming a better version of your worst
version of you
um because like there's some people who
have Partnerships like that's how we see
it like spouse Partnerships that like
all they do is emphasize the worst
character traits of you it's like if
your you know partner is always like
like no let's let's stay in or let's
let's drink or let's you know not to say
that those things are bad in small doses
but like if everything you have is
always like decreasing all your stats to
be with this person like long term for
people who are growth oriented which not
that many people are but for people who
are growth oriented I think having
somebody who holds you to a higher
standard like I know that Layla has
extremely high expectations of me and I
have very high expectations of her and
we just always want to exceed one
another's expectations as the bar
continues to rise because like as you
get better so too do your Alternatives
by like other people who you attract are
better quality and so we both want to be
in like you think about this way a
voluntary relationship like of all the
people I still want to be with you and
that like because what happens a lot of
people one person grows and the other
person doesn't and like
it's just like if one person's growing
they both have to grow yep I don't think
it's gonna work long term you know what
I think the biggest thing is it's like
the biggest gift that we've given
ourselves our relationship we do not
compare to anybody else's like like to a
degree that I've never even had the
thought about somebody else's
relationship and how it contrasts to
mine
because I think it's just like each
relationship is its own unique it's like
a unique organism like it shouldn't be
compared to anything else they're
Dynamics yeah and so I think we're two
unique people therefore we have a unique
relationship therefore why would I
compare it to anybody else I think
that's where most of like The Angst and
the resentment in so many relationships
come from is you're comparing to
somebody else's which they're two
completely different unique people in
different circumstances different life
goals different Mission different values
different interests so it's like why
would I describe their preferences to my
reality how developed do you think your
own character and value system and and
personality need to be developed before
you're ready to date and marry someone
or do you think that you go in kind of
you know a scribbles on a blanks you
know slate or whatever and then you get
into this relationship and then the
other person builds your values and
character and stuff like that I think
you got to be good being alone you think
you need to be already kind of
understanding you need to be yourself
person like if you if you're the person
who always has to have somebody there to
like Feel Complete
what you want in my opinion is two whole
people
that together like the sum of two holes
is significantly greater not two halves
making one hole I think it's like I want
at least this is Alex's Viewpoint of the
world yeah well I think we choose what
we are dependent on each other for right
like there there's a lot of stuff I
depend on Alex for and there's a lot of
stuff he depends on me for but it's
chosen we could do it on our own if we
didn't have each other you know what I
mean versus there's some people it's not
chosen it's like necessary and I think
that's when you have issues yeah that
makes sense it makes it seem much more
voluntary than just like feeling
compelled to join a relationship because
of something you need from the other
person 100 it's like I mean this is a
voluntary you know these are voluntary
relationships like and we want to set
ourselves up for Success which is like
don't
need anything yeah can you imagine
something like more beautiful than two
people who don't need one another who
just choose to be with the other because
they prefer life together like that in
my mind is like and if you continue to
prefer living life together then you
don't need
this any outside anything but wouldn't
you say that also takes a lot of dating
experience to know what to look for and
what you like and what you don't like I
think dating experience or education you
know what I mean I think like for me
like I read Tony Robbins I was Unleashed
to power within yeah and they had the
whole thing where you write down yeah
awaken the giant I don't even know what
that's doing which one it was right but
it was like write down everything
non-negotiables of what you would break
up with someone for and then the
characteristics here look at this whole
thing I had this whole exercise and like
I didn't know I have a ton of experience
like in in depth I mean you know I had
good significant relationships like
whatever you're young right I'm like 20
something
um but I had read that book and I was
like I trust that this person knows what
he's talking about he's seen enough
relationships if I do this formula I
feel like it will pan out and when we
were talking about getting married I was
like listen this I remember thinking I
was like Tony Robbins said that if you
do X Y and Z you know you you pick like
this which we did and then you go like
this and like you can work on pretty
pretty much everything else as long as
you get the fundamentals right like
basically get the fundamentals right of
like matching your expectations and
non-negotiables of what you're looking
for in a spouse and then everything else
you can create one of the things that I
think has been really important for
Layla and I at least uh so Warren
Buffett was in front of a crowd of
college kids and they and he said so who
here you know I get asked all the time
what if you could only have one
character trait that you look for in a
spouse what would you look for right and
people were like brains and beauty or
character loyalty right and he's like
you don't want any of that stuff he's
like you know what you want low
expectations he's like that's how you
create a marriage that lasts and like he
was being incredibly serious but also
tongue and cheek at the same time but I
think part of that process at least how
we approached it was that we were
probably the least Hollywood version of
a relationship you know what I mean like
we unhollywood everything it was very
much like does this make sense right and
I think because of that approach big
picture
neither of us came in expecting the
other person to save us you know what I
mean like I don't need you to make me
happy and I think that's where the whole
person comes in like if you're if you're
like I'm happy doing what I'm doing like
I I don't need you I prefer it but like
I can continue to live my life and the
other person can too then the
expectations are significantly lower
from the other person which is why like
for this is again me talking for me like
the fact that Layla never tried to
change me and still hasn't throughout
our whole relationship I think is one of
the biggest reasons why like you've been
good because like I resist anyone who
tries to change me very hard like her
Point earlier about like no rules
like I hate rules like tell me I can't
do something like there's like there's
nothing that drives me more mad than
something like that and so
because this may come like what if
circumstances change what you know I
mean like I hate it and so low
expectations and leading from values has
been how we've just used as our compass
pointing true north of mission and then
like we accept the waxes and wanes that
occur during the natural shifts of Time
how did you meet your wife all right you
guys are asking like the greatest hits I
love these questions okay so
uh my wife and I are a metoo story so
get ready for your channel to be
canceled uh I was teaching my wife was
my student and uh school for adults I
want to be very clear about that uh I
was teaching filmmaking and she was 21
at the time and she saw me at my best
and it was amazing and we hit it off
right away and when I met her I had
recently learned how to be good with
women because I was terrible up until
that point and truly how'd you learn oh
it's really simple you must be willing
to walk away
and you must be worthy I don't know your
audience well enough I'm going to give
you the truth you can edit it out if you
say the truth here here is the the
reality think about just hold it in your
mind for a second what sex really is
okay the the messy reality of what sex
is you have to go from high my name is
to that to do that you must be worthy of
that now you might be able to trick him
into doing it once but I've gotten my
wife to do that for 22 years you have to
be worthy so one you have to be worthy
two you have to have confidence meaning
you recognize your worth and because you
recognize your worth you're going to act
completely as you are who you are
because it does not make sense to get
somebody into a relationship that's not
going to work so broadcast who you are
and be willing to walk away so if you
are worthy of someone inviting you into
their body and that that is an amazing
incredible moment that you guys can
share and it's your real Partners in
that act because I'm very much NADA like
don't get with somebody that you you can
Dominate and push around get with
somebody who is your equal
we can go into that as much as you want
I have very strong feelings
but you want to do that and you need to
understand that you have that worth that
you've done the work that you're good at
something that matters and then that you
don't need that person and that even if
you feel like you need that person and
they're the only one for you and all
that the second you act like that they
will become elusive you'll never get
them and
you can't tolerate
the friend zone or anything like that
like I'll give you an example I never
had to say this to my wife but if I had
thought I was sliding into the friend
zone I would just say like hey if I'm
not what you're looking for totally
respect that you are lovely and I wish
you the best in everything I'm not
interested in the friend zone all the
best to you and you know if I can be a
reference or whatever let me know uh but
this is where we part ways and at that
point and I am very good at this I would
flip a switch in my mind and I would
never think about that person again you
just you how long did it take to develop
that sort of mindset though 23 years
really and what was there an event or an
inflection point where you're like oh
got it if you want to get good at
something find somebody who's already
good at that go to them and ask them
what do you do beg for the absolute
truth and then when they tell you
believe them I went to George
leonardopolis
George got laid left right and Center
and I said George secret Greek he is
great okay is he like a famous guy or
something not at all now he's just Greek
man and uh they're natural
charismatic that is as George was very
charismatic and very good looking and
did he have an accent though he did not
I grew up in America so he didn't have
that going for him but very Charming and
I said George what's the secret because
I am terrible with women and he said oh
you just have to be a dick to them and I
wanted to bang my head on the table and
I was like
one I know him and he isn't a dick so
he's saying something and it's so cliche
so finally I was like I'm not going to
reject this because the guy I know that
is the way that I want to be with women
is telling me that that's a secret he's
telling me insincerity he's wrong but
he's telling me sincerely so what does
he actually mean and then I realized oh
he's always himself and he's willing to
walk away
and I was like that's so interesting and
so he isn't like oh what do you want
what do you like which then just puts
you in this like you're there to to
placate them yeah like it just makes you
okay I'm just gonna say the real words
you you
in my estimation
if you want to be good with the typical
female you need to be self-assured
confident strong
um very good at something that they care
about and you need to embody all of that
and then you need to be wildly
interested in who they are make them
feel better about themselves when
they're around you than when they're not
and them feel like whoa this person
really lifts me up but they're honest
and they tell me the truth and they
don't ever pull punches and if they say
something that I don't like I'm going to
let them know that I don't like that
very calmly but just hey I like this I
don't like that
and I was shocked at how intoxicating
the woman who is now my wife and she
will be the first to tell you that it
didn't work only on her I had had a
chance to test this out before meeting
her and realize and it was night and day
could not get laid
flip a switch
very successful with women and was I was
laughing I was like I can't believe this
is true and then flashing back on my
life there was this girl that I really
liked in high school and she used to
always say when we're not dating you're
super cool and the second we're dating
you're not yourself and I couldn't
understand what she meant and so then I
played it back and I was like oh my God
it's because I had fear of loss and so
when we weren't dating and in fear of
loss because we weren't together so just
who I am that would get her attracted we
would date and then because I liked her
so much I had fear of loss so I started
trying to act the way I thought she
wanted me to act then I'm not
interesting there's no sort of power in
that there's just someone supplicating
themselves to you it's just not
interesting it's interesting so by
flipping that switch everything in my
life changed now I've only told one
woman that I loved her I've been in a
committed relationship for 22 years like
so if anybody thinks they hear me saying
I'm a lothario or a Playboy that's not
my life at all but I am telling you that
it is a game of psychology and if you
don't play it well you will lose and so
all the guys out there right now that
are losing it is 100 their fault it is
not Society it is nothing other than you
do not understand the psychology of the
person that you're sitting across from
that you're trying to effectively sell
yourself to and because I took the time
to actually figure out what that is the
complexities because right now you hear
red pills
be dominant they're your property oh
[__] the really terrible advice find
a partner find somebody who can
challenge you but be yourself challenge
them be worthy be good push yourself
every day be aggressive be
um hardcore try to take up as much space
as you can try to mansplain anything
that you're passionate about like don't
be hesitant at all and then shut up and
make sure that you're giving them that
space and you're drawing that out of
them and you show how much you respect
them and how interested you are in them
and find somebody you actually care
about so that this isn't a game and then
just be open and honest and it's
incredible my wife is my equal in every
conceivable way on balance but there are
things that I am way better than her at
and in those moments I lead
and there are things that she's way
better than Mia and in those moments I
follow and because I can do both of
those but I am not at all afraid to take
the lead
then you get an interesting Dynamic how
has your Dynamic changed over 20 years
oh brother so when she became an
entrepreneur that was the rockiest
period in our life because she had been
a stay-at-home wife for eight years so I
had somebody that cooked for me cleaned
for me took care of our puppies laid my
clothes out literally my clothes would
be laying at the end of the bed uh So my
gym clothes would be set out my work
clothes would be set out I did not have
to think of anything she sorted it all
all of our personal things flights trips
family my mom was going to get a
birthday gift all it's just all sorted
out I have to think about any
she started thinking hey maybe I
actually like this entrepreneur thing
and then it was like you know she was
stepping into a far more aggressive
personality type like really starting to
feel her own and getting involved in
areas of business that had been sort of
my domain and the space that made me
feel cool and
that was a hard thing to navigate and so
what I told her was you have to give me
the opportunity to mourn and so because
the relationship I thought we were going
to have where you were going to be my
wife we're gonna have kids you were
going to stay at home take care of the
kids that's gone I don't get that
anymore and that was the the thing that
we got married based around so let me
mourn that but I want you to be whoever
you want to be and it would violate my
value system if I respond to in any way
other than I want to help you become the
best version of yourself the way that
you define it and so we've got all kinds
of standard operating procedures Rules
of Engagement that it would take me a
long time and I'm happy to answer
anything on that about how we ended up
making that work
how we did a transition period where she
slowly over like a week or two weeks
weaned me off of okay I'm setting out
some of your clothes not all of them I'm
making some of your meals but not all of
them down to okay now you're
self-sufficient we divide you know the
different work that has to be done all
that stuff
um and it's absolutely incredible but
you then if you're doing things that are
overlapping you have to be very
thoughtful about who has more expertise
in one area over the other should always
listen to each other you should want
disconfirming evidence but if you can't
agree on something you have to have a
rule of Engagement around what are you
going to do when you can't agree so for
instance I am the right person between
the two of us to be the CEO she will be
the first to admit it so when we founded
the company I and my Act of making sure
that she feels what she needs to feel
which is that I believe she is my equal
and she is my partner and she is my
priority the lawyer said look you need
to split the company 51 49 we don't care
who has 50 51 percent who has 49 but to
avoided legal nightmare you must do that
and Lisa was like Tom will take 51 and I
was like Over My Dead Body we are 50 50
equal Partners make the ultimate divorce
nightmare I have failed if I don't have
enough influence over her that I can
navigate this process and I'm so
confident that I want what's good for
her and will sacrifice half of my [__]
to make sure that her life is good why
would I ever do that I also know who she
is barring head trauma she she's never
going to ask for more than half of the
business I'm just utterly convinced of
that and so make that the nightmare but
wife of mine let's be very clear if we
ever Collide on an idea and you can't
convince me and I can't convince you
which we will both try very very hard
and we will respect each other and
really listen and really talk but if
after all of that we can't agree we will
go with my idea every single time are
you okay with that yes cool then we can
March forward
now if in that moment I had been like oh
well I think how do you feel like that's
never going to work because the reality
is I'm not willing to do this if that
isn't true because I am the right person
to make those decisions so
you have to have the clarity of knowing
when you're the right person you have to
have the historical track record of oh I
follow you whenever you're the right
person I back off you know that in your
bones you know that I listen you know
that I'm not saying this from ego I'm
saying this from we recognize what each
other's skill sets are and that happens
to be mine so anyway getting to that
high level communication that's what
people have to be able to do and every
day pushing yourself to be a better
version of yourself like that [__] is
hard but if you do that for 30 40 years
you can be in real beast mode but
growing together is the hard part
because things are going to change and
if you can't navigate those moments well
you're in trouble you didn't ask this
but I have one more this is on my mind
no I'm so into this all right so there's
one more thing that people really have
to be thoughtful about there is a reason
that so many marriages break up around
the 25-year Mark I always thought it was
because they had kids and that's when
kids leave the house now I'm sure that
can be a big thing that breaks up
marriages for sure but my wife and I
don't have kids and we have found our
marriage isn't in danger but we found
this new thing that we're colliding over
that I'm like oh my God I see how this
plays out in a couple that doesn't have
the tools that we have what ends up
happening is over time so you should
marry somebody that has a different
world views than you you don't want
somebody that thinks the same as you you
want someone with the same values you do
not want somebody that thinks the same
so my wife and I come at things very
differently I see how things could work
she sees how things will break that has
made us an incredible pair
so we each have these World Views and
over time life kicks you in the face you
learn a lesson and your world view
refines and it gets more robust and more
robust but remember you each have
different World Views but they're
becoming more solidified over time so
now 25 years into your relationship
you've got dramatically Different World
Views and you know that your worldview
is right and so now you've got these two
World Views that start clashing all the
time and you can't break them out of it
I just tweeted out about this today you
have to be very careful you can't want
people to think the way you think
because otherwise your world view will
solidify and it will become a prison and
so what happens is life teaches you the
way you approach the world is right the
way you invest is right the way you run
your YouTube channel is right look at
all your success now imagine that going
for 25 years now you're just like I'm
right like I don't know what do you want
me to say like this works man all My
Success everything that we've done it's
right it's right it's right but you have
different World Views and you both
believe they're right so unless you are
hungry to find that area oh okay I can't
argue from the place of I'm right and
you're wrong but we both have to argue
from the fact that I believe I'm right I
feel right
and getting my solution my way will
yield what I want and the same is true
for you so now we're colliding over
something where it's not that you're
wrong it's
gets very complicated you can't even see
what I'm thinking and feeling you hear
all the words but you don't see the
world through my distorted mirror you
see the world do your distorted mirror
so I can't see what you're saying
because I don't see the world through
your distorted mirror so now you you
have to go okay we're both smart people
who love each other we're colliding we
each think the other person is crazy
which is why you're getting upset
because you think how can you live life
like that it's so ridiculous
so you're like okay at this moment I
have to say even though I really really
believe that you would be better off
doing things my way like I can steal man
your argument I can tell you what your
argument is this is not confusion
even though I can do that I think you're
crazy and I don't want to do it that way
you have to have a rule of Engagement
for how do we approach this problem and
this is where most people break because
in that moment you're going to have to
do something sub optimally
and your marriage has to be the thing
you want to protect the most because
oftentimes my wife and I will collide or
something around the business so now she
could be [__] with millions of
dollars and I have to be willing to lose
that money to protect my marriage
because I'm going to have to compromise
to some point on certain things it gets
complicated because I know that first
thing I said if we disagree it's always
going to be my idea but hey you've got
to contextualize if you're beating
someone to death all the time all the
time all the time like you're just gonna
demotivate them so even though by
agreement I could it's not wise
I want this to get too complicated so
you have to be willing to compromise
there may be real consequences to that
compromise and you have to want that
marriage their ability to have high
self-esteem and to feel loved and
appreciated and to feel like you're
equal
you've got to want that for them so
badly that you will compromise on some
of the things you want and they have to
be willing to do the same if you can do
all of that it's everything man because
there are going to be moments where I
will just tell you a person loving you
and going to bat for you and being there
for you in the ups and the downs and
helping you think through the hardest
problems and not judging you when they
see you at your worst that is so much
better than money there's nothing
nothing I've tried it all there's
nothing better than that at least if
you're hardwired like I am so my
understanding
is that for conflict resolution between
a married couple that's been going on
for a while the best thing is to
acknowledge and to be mindful that there
is a distorted window for yourself and
absolutely critical there is no
objective right and wrong
which we can get into I'm going to give
you a quick hypothesis I'm not sure I'm
right about the reason yet I know I'm
right about the the symptom I don't know
if I'm right about the cause there's a
guy named Donald Hoffman yeah who
believes that all of the world is
basically a computer interface and if
you think about reality as being the
electrical switches that are either on
or off that's the reality of a computer
that's the reality of sending an email
that's the reality of playing Grand
Theft Auto but you don't interface with
it like that you send an email by click
clacking on a keyboard to make little
words appear on the screen but what's
really happening is electrical circuits
going on and off really fast to process
zeros and ones okay that's too
complicated so his belief is that we
evolve to have this user interface and
now we're just dealing with the world
through the user interface
he's right and it feels like even though
it may not be literally true the outcome
makes that feel like it's true then you
know my distorted mirror is really just
my version of that interface not it
doesn't represent what is real
objectively we're not at the laws of
physics level
so since I know that I'm not dealing
with the the on and off I'm just dealing
with an interpretation of it becomes
much easier to have this conversation of
I just recognize that my worldview is an
abstraction
so everything I believe is not it's not
literal truth I'm just dealing in the
the realm of psychology what we can call
symptoms of whatever the underlying
thing is that has helped me a lot to get
out of my own way to not be like well I
know I'm right that this really is a
black coffee mug where my wife's like
it's gray what are you talking about
it's blue it's like you start to realize
yeah that might actually be how it's
represented for you with your computer
interface or your distorted mirror to
stick with one metaphor and so that
becomes easier to to stop thinking I'm
right and therefore we need to do what I
say when did you start thinking that way
this is going to surprise you in terms
of the answer when I was 14 15
I really wanted to be good with girls
and I wasn't
and so that began a very long journey of
what is it that I have to learn to get
good that led me to reading Cosmo
magazine which led me to thinking about
women through a psychological lens and
then
my mother gave me the best piece of
advice your audience is going to be very
surprised by the term this interview is
taken my mom gave me the best piece of
advice around women that I've ever gone
to this day and she said women need to
trust you in order to have an orgasm and
I was like what I'm sorry like how old
are you uh probably 15 16 and so I was
just like ah
trust doesn't even enter into the
equation for me I don't even need to
know their name so that was so strange
and it just made me go whoa I'm I'm
having one Experience One frame of
reference over here but for somebody
else it it is such foreign territory
that I have to begin to understand what
is true and so that put me on this Quest
that led me to
neuroplasticity the human ability to
improve all of this stuff ends up paying
dividends because for a long time I
didn't think I'd ever be successful I
didn't think I was smart enough I didn't
realize that you could get better I had
a fixed mindset all this stuff but so
all these little pieces start coming
together with the Dao de Jing long story
uh so I start cobbling this idea
together that you can step outside of
your frame of reference which I wouldn't
have known to call it that then
and more thought of it as different
brains see the world in different ways
and if you can understand how they see
it then you can find a way to translate
well this is how I feel but I need to
translate it into your language to make
you feel what I want you to feel so
something my wife and I talk a lot about
it doesn't matter what you say matters
what the other person understands so to
get to that then you have to go oh well
the female brain is very different from
the male brain I understand it's highly
controversial but I'll just tell you
real life's gonna slap you in the mouth
if you want to argue that point and so
by embracing that and so how do you
define truth it'll be an easy way truth
is
if I believe it and act as if it were
true does my prediction engine work or
break when I look at the world with the
assumption that the female brain is
different and very specific and
predictable ways I can predict the
outcome of my actions bouncing off my
wife just as an example
better than if I assume she views the
world in the same way that I do if I
group women into a rough group and I
make predictions about my behaviors and
the response I will get from them based
on putting them in a group and of course
huge distribution we have way more in
common than we have separate where
compared to other things we're basically
the same but if you have if you operate
with that you'll find that your
prediction engine is way better at
predicting outcomes and so the more you
get into steering your life by
I believe they're saying to be true any
it's a hypothesis scientific method
tells me any hypothesis makes a
prediction if that prediction holds true
then the hypothesis becomes a thesis so
I'm just constantly trying to get my
best guess which is my hypothesis tested
to see if the predictions it makes
actually are true and when they are then
I upgrade that thing to a thesis I never
say it's fact or it's true largely
because of the Donald Hoffman problem so
I'm constantly looking for that
disconfirming evidence that will give me
a better way to perceive what's
happening so my prediction engine would
be even better
and so you refine refine refine let's
say you're in a relationship with a girl
for a couple of years how do you know
that this is the one that you should
spend the rest of your life with like
what are the pillars to a successful
marriage I asked Alex and Layla hormozy
this question they gave me a very
similar answer to what I thought the
answer was and I want to know your
opinion yes so what you're looking for
is shared values
but complementary World Views so again
to give the example between Lisa and I
I'm uh move towards something Lisa's
largely move away I look and see
opportunity no matter what I'm very
um I don't mind risk at all and Lisa is
more risk-averse she sees how things
could break she's about systems and
process and so when you put us together
once we realized that we needed to Value
the tension between the two of us and
that it's what makes a kite work you
need a kite and a string if you have
just the kite the wind will blow it into
nothingness it will crash land in a tree
end up on the ground whatever if you
have just a string it lays on the ground
but you have a kite and a string the
dynamic tension between the two if they
both respect each other now it can keep
that kite Aloft so she's a string I'm
the kite neither of us are useful
without the other but we have core
values that are the same so for both of
us our marriage is our number one
priority we have certain views around
family communication uh what to pursue
not pursue so just a lot a lot of shared
values so look for that and then because
I am such a huge love junkie I think you
want to look for somebody that makes you
feel like there's no way that two people
have ever felt like this before at the
beginning you have to understand that
the neurochemistry that's going to
change over time but that moment of like
yo I'm so into this person because if
you're not into that person because it
will get hard and when you ask yourself
why am I with this person if you don't
know you're in trouble and then the last
thing I will say is I highly recommend
especially the men to do some sort of
ritualistic scarification
so it could be as simple as a tattoo
that's what I did but you want to it
only worked for me because I it's the
only tattoo I have I'm not like a tattoo
guy if you're a tattoo guy it's not
going to work but you want to do
something permanent that will remind you
you are a different person before you
get married than after so immediately
after getting married I took a tattoo
that I design and give to my wife as a
wedding present
and got it tattooed and the whole time I
did it I wanted to focus on the pain
wanted to focus on the permanence and
that I was doing this specifically to be
a different person at the end of this
came from a book called The Power of
myth where he talks about one of the
reasons he thought that so many
marriages fell apart is there's no
meaningful ritual that demarcates single
life from married life and so then I did
a lot of things around really thinking
about my willingness to die for my wife
and all of that and so just spending an
inordinate amount of time thinking about
that my wife and I never even joke about
divorce we didn't say that word in our
house we call it the d word so there is
no exit it's there look there are things
neither of us would stay in an abusive
or Loveless marriage
um but it's our job to make sure that it
never gets there and may have a lot of
tools and tactics to make sure that we
don't get there but it should be the
most amazing thing in your life Bar None
So now it's the end and thank you guys
for making it all the way through jack
uh what happened two months of some
relationship discussion uh how were
things with you and Macy great really
fantastic dive into that a little bit
never been better what do you mean by
great fantastic yeah I mean I mean it's
significantly above average
where's that put average at average is
average is good yeah so this is like
significantly above good it's great yeah
and would you say that you feel
supported by her and you support her yes
what is the one thing that sticks above
all else about Macy that you just love
hmm very caring and I think selfless I
think selfless is a good word for her
thanks for tuning in no look at my Jack
okay what happened two months ago you
said you said you wished that you got a
haircut sooner no yeah I mean that was
just a joke I was just riffing I mean
realistically I think I look better with
the longer hair and I've had more
success with longer hair than I have
with shorter hair so
I don't believe it
you're not present when I'm going on
dates
not a ton enough to you know do you
actually do you actually see a
difference between long and short hair
yes how yeah if I cut my hair short uh
if there's any girl I'm talking to at
that time they're just like ah I just
liked you better with the longer are you
serious yes I swear do they leave or
what happened no
that leave me yeah then like hey come
back sorry I don't know what happened
and just like no they just like they'll
flat out say it yeah they know I'm I I
can take criticism and I I'm fine
hearing stuff like that so they just
flat out say it I find it odd a couple
accounts yeah for the past like five
years man this is why I'm so
apprehensive to cut my hair short do you
like it shorter no
no really really
I think so no you should grow out your
hair long man I think you're really good
like a seagulls look or maybe like you
know down to your shoulders no no I
think it looks so bad with long hair
couldn't do it well that's everything
you guys need to know about
relationships thank you so much for
tuning in to this episode and we'll see
you on Sunday see you next time